when you're a global superstar like kim
kardashian everyone's going to have an
opinion about you it is what it is but
the 41 year old kkw beauty founder says
her biggest critic lives a little close
to home
no like she actually lives in kim's home
it's a different experience for sure
on tuesday the skim's founder spoke
during vogue's forces of fashion
conference revealing that when it comes
to fashion her eight-year-old daughter
northwest always has an opinion
you just gotta roll with it quote north
is very opinionated when it comes to
what i'm wearing she'll always complain
when i'm wearing too much black
having a strong opinion a love for
fashion sounds like north takes after
her famous dad kanye west she definitely
has kanye's outgoing personality
and will say whatever is on her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend and then she's also really calm
and sweet like me sometimes as for kim
she says she showed up at her daughter's
school on valentine's day wearing head
to toe pink and the look had northey's
seal of approval
quote she got so excited she ran over
and hugged me she opened my coat saw the
black lining and says mom you're still
wearing black
of course this is hardly the first time
north has trolled kim i don't know how
you're going to top that who could
forget when she called out her mom last
year for using a different voice when
she posts on social media
okay i'm going to open it and show you
guys
what do you talk differently why do i
talk different for what when i do videos
for my videos i'm the same human being i
don't talk different
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot oh and how
about that time she interrupted kim
while the mama four was trying to show
off some swag she received from olivia
rodrigo to promote the singer's album
sour
cute as olivia rodrigo you guys
i can't wait for her album you guys know
i love driver's license
look she sent a box of tissues
yeah she straight up just said kim
doesn't listen to olivia
that was like so inappropriate
yes i do i listen to it all the time
and back in 2020 kim and kanye's little
girl totally crashed her psa about
social distancing amid the coronavirus
pandemic
hi everyone in california it's kim
kardashian west and i just wanted to
talk to you and north west
i know
that can you not jump on the bed give me
like two seconds to seriously do this
and let's not forget this classic moment
i'm hiding in the guest room you guys
i'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids
will not leave me alone
hey that's me
can i please just do my little tutorial
i i it's all i want to do is one little
fun thing for myself
north's personality is so big she even
inspired a super popular fan account
nori's black book which was featured on
the famous family's hit reality show
keeping up with the kardashians
so we walk
into the restaurant and we get to meet
nori's black book she is everything and
more everything and more but we i was
convinced it was someone that we knew
e.t caught up with the founder of the
account last year who dished on how the
whole thing came to be
north was born and you know they had the
babies rs line the kardashians they put
her in the outfit and i remember saying
can you imagine how upset north probably
is because she's probably like i swear
in chanel balenciaga supreme like
something else but i'm in this cheap
baby's rs clothes and so like a light
bulb went off and i was like oh that's
it this is like the thing
[Music]